Привіт, мамуль. Привіт!
Матір Тетяни - 69-річну пенсіонерку Валентину Іванівну Сень
- родичі змогли поховати тут, на місцевому кладовищі, лише через кілька тижнів після її смерті.
Російські окупанти розстріляли її 25 березня 2022 року на власному подвір’ї,
де вона пролежала до моменту деокупації.
Всю окупацію мама була в цьому шарфику.
Це все, що залишилося від неї.
Ще молода й енергійна жіночка була.
Не несла їм загрози, вони просто позбавили її життя.
І нас тим самим, втратився сенс життя.
Донька Тетяна перші тижні окупації пережила поруч з мамою.
Однак у день її вбивства не була поруч.
Напередодні вона евакуювалася з дитиною до Києва.
Мама Валентина їхати не захотіла.
Те, що сталося з пенсіонеркою, бачили сусіди жінки.
Ходила по воду якраз там, де стояли солдати.
Заїхали ці солдати і почали просто стріляти.
Просто так стріляти, вони були злі.
А в цей момент мама розмовляла по телефону.
Вона злякалась і почала бігти.
І вони по ній почали стріляти, не поцілили.
Вона забігла додому, ще встигла за собою закрити двері,
і її через двері настигла куля.
Через цю дірку маму вбили.
Куля печінку пробила, мама просто стекла кров’ю.
Через рік після вбивства матері Тетяна ще жодного разу не була на допиті у слідчих.
У квітні 2022-го покази давав лише її син,
який особисто ховав бабусю і першим знайшов її мертвою,
коли в місто зайшли ЗСУ.
Нам не телефонували і нічого.
Я навіть не знаю, чи є справа.
Батька Сергія - Олександра Яреміча
- росіяни теж убили в той день - 25 березня, незадовго до деокупації Київщини.
Він розносив місцевим у Бучі харчі та воду,
неподалік російських блокпостів.
Вісьмох його приятелів на початку місяця
розстріляли на цьому місці по вулиці Яблунській.
Батька - через два тижні після них
- так само неподалік після обшуків у будинку.
Коли військові зайшли безпосередньо у двір, де був мій батько,
вони побачили, що крім чотирьох чоловіків був ще п’ятий, і позабирали телефони.
Наказали пройти далі, в лісочок, за кінець вулиці.
Прозвучав спочатку один постріл, далі - три. Ну, і тиша…
До сьогодні син Олександра протягом року щомісяця дзвонив правоохоронцям,
аби з’ясувати статус справи про вбивство батька.
Втім, спершу довго тривала ексгумація та збір доказів,
а через кілька місяців - поміняли слідчого.
Лише нещодавно у Сергія відбувся перший допит.
Повільно, але прогрес все ж таки є.
Вони звітують, що вони зробили, кажуть, який процес наступний.
Але наразі це довготривалий процес.
Сумніваюся, що навіть через рік це закінчиться.
За минулий рік, розповідає заступник керівника Київської обласної прокуратури,
слідчі СБУ здійснили повне обстеження деокупованої території регіону,
провели ексгумації та зібрали усі докази щодо наявних справ.
Випадків воєнних злочинів, зокрема фізичної наруги над цивільним населенням,
нарахували майже 11 тисяч,
щодо них вже відкрито понад 7 тисяч кримінальних проваджень.
Підозрюваних - 118, а заочно перед судом постали 50 осіб.
З них чотирьом винесено вироки.
Допомагали слідчим зі збором такої кількості даних про воєнні злочини волонтери
- у складі організованих груп з документування.
Причина тривалого слідства, пояснюють в обласній прокуратурі, комплексна:
складно встановити осіб злочинців та неможливо затримати таких людей фізично.
Наразі ми робимо роботу, яка необхідна для суспільства.
І за кожен їхній злочин у нас має бути зібрана доказова база.
Так, деяка частина людей буде притягнута заочно,
інша частина - після нашої перемоги.
У цьому році, я думаю, ми ще отримаємо велику кількість вироків.
Після цього людина буде знаходитися в міжнародному розшуку,
і Україною підписано низку міжнародних правових угод щодо видачі злочинців.
Крім розслідувань у самій Україні нині понад 20 країн світу відкрили,
в межах свого національного законодавства,
провадження щодо воєнних злочинів Росії.
Окремим напрямком слідства є провадження щодо злочинів
з боку вищого політичного керівництва РФ.
Це 642 підозрювані, серед яких
- очільник російського міноборони, генштабу, розвідки, депутати Держдуми, Центробанку.
Нещодавно ордери на арешт президента Володимира Путіна
та уповноваженої з прав дитини в Росії Марії Львової-Бєлової
видав Міжнародний кримінальний суд у Гаазі.
Це, кажуть правники, лише початок, але це вагомий крок
у притягненні злочинців до відповідальності.
Цей ордер має надзвичайно велике значення не тільки тому,
що це фактично визнання наявності доказів злочину,
а ще й тому, що це ордер має стримуючий, запобіжний фактор.
Оцінка цих діянь може трансформуватися,
і вони можуть бути перекваліфіковані, зокрема, на геноцид.
На даному етапі правник і кандидат юридичних наук Денис Азаров
вбачає кілька напрямків роботи для українського та міжнародного слідства.
Перший - створення в Україні окремої спеціальної групи,
яка буде займатися розслідуванням воєнних злочинів, вчинених російськими солдатами.
Інший напрямок - міжнародне доведення факту геноциду щодо українського народу з боку РФ.
Для цього важливою є ратифікація Римського статуту Міжнародного кримінального суду, зауважує правник.
Адже це дозволить поширити юрисдикцію цього суду на територію України
і розглядати справи щодо злочинів, скоєних тут.
Поки що в Гаазькому суді підписали угоду про створення офісу прокурора МКС в Україні.
Тим часом родичі вбитих цивільних унаслідок окупації з боку РФ поки не мають офіційного статусу,
а окремі докази та свідчення - не закріплені юридично без спеціальних рішень суду.
Практики не існує! Це вперше, по суті кажучи, така ситуація.
Стовідсотковий результат встановлений бути не може.
Хоча б тому, що мені видається нереалістичним встановити абсолютно всіх,
хто вчиняв злочини від "найменшого" в лапках до всіх причетних до геноциду української нації.
Треба мати чітку стратегію і розуміти,
які посягання будуть розслідуватися суто в межах національного законодавства,
а які мають бути передані на розгляд Міжнародного кримінального суду.
Ця вулиця стала називатися дорогою смерті.
На цій вулиці вбивали людей без розбору.
Костянтин Гудаускас - волонтер з Казахстану, який на власні очі бачив трупи цивільних,
вбитих у Бучі на вулиці Яблунській під час окупації.
У ті дні рік тому він як волонтер евакуював мирних жителів звідси до Києва.
Після деокупації Костянтин особисто долучився до документування злочинів росіян
і почав ділитися своїми свідченнями про все побачене.
Але не на судах - туди його ще не запросили, а у документальному фільмі "Буча",
який за рік вже показали у десятках країн Європи.
Світ має побачити, як це відбувалося, як це відбувається.
Світ саме завдяки художнім фільмам має відчути біль,
який відчувають українці.
Це буде впливати на політичні рішення,
дуже важливі для нашої країни.
Я в шоці був від того, що комісія ООН не знайшла геноциду.
Всю ніч не спав і думав, якби цих людей до братських могил, до діточок вбитих!
Це геноцид! Людей убивали, бо вони - українці.
І Сергій, син вбитого мешканця Бучі Олександра,
і Тетяна - донька розстріляної Валентини чули про документальний фільм "Буча"
та ще близько десятка подібних стрічок в Україні і за кордоном.
Втім, кажуть: на душі стане спокійно,
коли російські окупанти та їхні керівники понесуть реальне покарання
- не у кіно, а в житті.
Я дуже хочу, щоб ця країна відповіла за цей злочин.
І саме таке тяжке розуміння, що ті люди,
які живуть там, вони це все підтримують…
Тетяна не виключає, що вбивці її матері і так уже можуть бути мертві.
Вона вірить: фінальний акт правосуддя, якого чекають усі українці,
таки відбудеться на міжнародному рівні.